welcome to who's there a show about
cloud identity
[Music]
in the last episode of who's there I
talked about why identity platform is
awesome and how to enable it in your GCP
project today I'm showing you how to
integrate identity platform into your
iOS app and Swift if you haven't enabled
identity platform yet I recommend you
check out the last episode of who's
there before proceeding you also need an
iOS app Emacs codes start with an
existing app or create a new single view
app and if iOS isn't your jam then check
out the getting started videos for
Android or web both link below alright
with all the prerequisites out of the
way let's get started in the cloud
console for my project I selected the
identity platform tab I previously added
email and password authentication if you
haven't edited this yet click add a
provider and select email password there
are lots of other providers to explore
but with today I'm just sticking with
this one on this providers page you see
a link in the upper right for
application setup details this pops up a
window with brief getting started
information when I click the iOS tab I
see
to get started with iOS you'll need to
register it and add firebase
configuration to your app learn more I
click get started with firebase which
takes me to an entirely new console some
of the information is the same as the
cloud console like project name and ID
but then there are all these new tabs
down the side that say develop quality
analytics and grow and the big pop up in
the middle asking about data sharing
if you've used firebase before this
probably looks familiar
but it's entirely possible you've never
even heard of firebase let alone used it
let's talk about what's going on here
firebase is a suite of products to help
you build your app and grow your user
base it includes SDKs for Objective C
and Swift for iOS Java and Kotlin for
Android JavaScript for web as well as
several frameworks like angular they're
specific for game SDKs for unity and C++
and so much more in fact I can make a
whole
series of videos just on firebase but
fortunately the firebase team has
already done that if you're interested
in finding out more about any of these
SDKs check out the documentation and the
firebase YouTube channel both linked
below now in many ways firebase is the
perfect complement to Google cloud very
broadly speaking Google cloud products
focus on server-side solutions like App
Engine compute engine cloud functions
kubernetes Engine and cloud run and
firebase products focus on client-side
solutions like authentication Cloud
messaging cloud storage for firebase and
so on I admit that's challenging to pin
down the relationship between Google
cloud and firebase so my oversimplified
explanation is that firebase is the way
to access some Google cloud platform
products from a client application
specifically for identity platform
this explanation works well the firebase
auth SDKs enable you to access identity
platform functionality from your client
app with that in mind let's head back to
that firebase console the firebase
console automatically opened to our
project notice this UI indicates that
QuickStart is already a firebase project
when adding identity platform to a
Google cloud project a firebase project
is automatically created first let's
deal with this pop-up it's up to you
whether you want to check off to use the
default settings for Google Analytics
data or select do this later some fire
based products depend on analytics like
a be testing so if you decide to
incorporate other features you probably
want to enable this again it's up to you
when you click on the project settings
notice the settings are identical to the
QuickStart cloud project firebase has
basically added some more details and
functionality to the cloud project
similar to when you enable an API or add
software from the marketplace since you
want to add identity platform to an iOS
app select add app iOS this gives you a
window with a series of steps to follow
keep in mind that the bun why do you
choose needs to match the bundle ID
your iOS app the app nickname is totally
up to you
I won't provide an app store ID since I
don't have one yet but if you do have
one feel free to add it here before
creating the app I'm now prompted to
download a Google service info.plist
file this file informs my iOS app about
my firebase up so I can interface with
firebase products once downloaded add
this to your iOS project click Next in
the console and it gives the next step
add the desired pods so I will be using
cocoapods to add the required
dependencies but you can add the
required code without cocoapods
check out the guide linked below to find
out how to install the SDKs without
cocoa pods ok initialize a new pod file
and then open it
add the firebase out the pendency and
then save the pod file close Xcode to
prevent strange behaviors that can
rarely happen when running cocoa pods
while the project is open then run pod
install open the created XC workspace
all right in the project in app delegate
import firebase this smart import will
only import the dependencies you need so
you don't really have to import firebase
off specifically for example in the dig
finish launching with options function
initialize the firebase app using
firebase app configure this initializes
the firebase app using the settings
provided by the Google service
info.plist file ok you can now use the
firebase offense DK to sign up talk in
log out and get user info about an
identity platform user identity platform
gives you access to many different login
providers including federated identity
providers like Google Facebook and
Twitter you can enable several login
methods for an app allowing your users
to authenticate the way that they prefer
some login methods may require
additional steps which are listed in the
console when you enable that login
method see the documentation below for
information on how to implement other
login providers for now let's get back
to implementing email and password login
back in the cloud console create a fake
user with a test email and a test
password of course you can also create a
new user from the client but this is a
good way to get us up and running really
quickly see how to create a user in your
iOS app following the link below back in
your iOS app and Xcode go to the
viewdidload
for your view controller call Auto
sign-in and pass the email and password
you just created in the console this
function passes a completion handler
with two parameters an optional octet a
result and an optional error that a
result is the result of sign and request
containing both the user and some
additional user info first I check that
off that a result has a value and if it
doesn't log the error otherwise I can do
whatever I need to do with the user
right now
I'll just log that users UID now of
course my example thus far is not a
complete off solution you need a way for
users to create accounts handle password
resets and log out each of these
functions needs some UI development as
well if you prefer you can write all
this functionality yourself using the
firebase SDKs the related documentation
is linked below but you also have the
option to use the firebase off UI module
this open source UI was created by off
specialists at Google includes all of
the views you would need to create an
account login logout and reset password
which you can incorporate in just a few
lines of code and you can override the
view controller classes to change the
appearance of your login whether you
make your own UI or use firebase UI you
will very likely need a way to know the
auth status before programming any app
actions for example you're going to want
to check if there is a user logged in
before writing to the database
that's where firebase auth listener
comes into play
let's look at how to implement it I
create a function I'm calling listen for
off changes in this function I call auth
dot off
got ad state change listener this
function passes a closure with an
optional user and optional error handle
the error if one is found then do what
you need with this user like assign the
value of a class's user to the logged in
user for the purpose of this example
I'll just log the user email then I'm
actually going to log out so you can see
the state change listener closure be
triggered again I put the code to log
out in the separate function here called
logout I run the app and the console
logs show that the user is logged in and
then logged out congratulations you just
added identity platform to an iOS app
ready to see what else sides on any
platform can do check out the firebase
off iOS guides all QuickStart code and
the firebase YouTube channel and be sure
to subscribe to the Google cloud
platform channel so you can be the first
to know about new videos in this who's
their series thanks for watching I'll
see you on the next episode
[Music]
you
[Music]